the jurgen experience you had
difficulties in making films but is
there ever a film that you wanted to
make that you never could
yeah sure what is that uh several uh
milai
me life i got very close we were about
two three weeks away from shooting it in
in uh thailand and some of it in vietnam
i've been to
milan and vietnam great story because
the massacre is unknown they don't know
we don't
people don't know the real story it was
investigated
that massacre you've heard of it right
i've heard 500 civilians were shot down
in cold blood babies
mother everybody every old people shot
and not one enemy bullet was fired not
one
and we've heard all the obfuscations of
that the whole thing was you know
basically a misplanned operation because
of
basically cia it was guiding the war and
they were
torturing to death uh some no torturing
some poor soul who gave him information
that was faulty
happens all the time right torture works
right
torture doesn't work uh and as a result
that of
the operation they were told that there
was nva in that village
they were not there so the guys went in
thinking they should kill
did you write a screenplay for this i no
someone else did and i was about to
direct it
and it was a it almost happened it just
ran into the uh fiscal crisis of 2008.
okay but that's not an excuse nobody
wanted to make it
have you thought about trying again i
did yeah no no go
i also tried to make the martin luther
king story years ago
many years i worked on it martin luther
king is a great story but it's a too
tough a story to tell
i mean i think there's a lot portion of
the black community
that's really kind of treats him like a
saint martyr
whereas this is more of a human man and
his fault you know his failings and this
and that but he's a hero in this
but you know his relationship with women
is fascinating
and we were into that whole aspect of it
and what happened with that
it just never got together never man
might be a good time to revisit that now
no i think it's a black filmmaker could
be visited right it's definitely moved
into that direction i've also tried
i tried for many years to do a vita and
uh
i wrote a script for that but if another
director made it
how far down the road had you gotten
with the martin luther king story
twice i went yeah i wrote a
mean and someone else wrote a whole
script it was i think it's very good
but gone you know you can't so many
films get planned and not made for every
film you do this like five
five abortions damn that seems like a
great one though
yeah i mean he's such a
an incredible and important character
and boy does a world need a martin
luther king jr right now
yeah well things are changing all the
time
[Applause]